welcome to this free webinar
this webinar is going to be focused on
bioinformatics for
genomic medicine and this is an
opportunity to learn
about both the future of medicine but
also to see how big data and
computational biology
data analysis curation and
interpretation
are all very vital to the improved
healthcare
and a solution for the growing needs of
patients and healthcare systems around
the world
but today we'll specifically focus on
the opportunities
in computational biology training and
support for
clinical research that we are launching
in africa to help a growing community of
clinicians
biomedical researchers university
students
and industry professionals
for those joining us for the first time
my name is elia brodsky i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
our company vision is to enhance human
health and well-being by enabling
biological research and discovery with
relevant data
solutions and support our mission is to
simplify bioinformatics
and advance research through the modular
and intuitive multi-economics analysis
platform that is powered by human
experience and artificial intelligence
we offer training research support and
big data analytics tools
designed for biomedical discovery and
our mission is to support
the cutting edge innovative projects and
solve
big data challenges by developing
innovative solutions that are easy to
use
and to provide training to use them
effectively and arrive at sound and
reproducible results
i'm honored to have been working at pine
biotech with many others including pine
biotech co-founders
dr alfred tauber and dr lena brodsky
both of them come
with years of expertise in oncology
immunology virology
as well as bioinformatics and
biostatistics so what we'll discuss
today is also a result of hard work by
our growing team
julia panoff who is an expert
bioinformatician has helped prepare many
of the materials that we will use
abi ttypsky who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of the
tbionfor platform
mohit mazumner who is in charge of
business development of kind
biotech joshua mckendall who maintains
the educational web portal we will
leverage
and beeps of biswas our online community
manager and support specialist
who i'm sure many of you have the chance
to interact with already
over the past several years we have
conducted
a large number of programs at various
university campuses around the world
working with faculty researchers and
students to build a collection
of modular coursework that cover the
important data types
bioinformatics methods and applications
in bioinformatics these include
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics and other types of onyx
and we
have seen how they have helped many
students build a great foundation
for understanding how to apply these
different technologies
and methods of analysis that are
useful in all kinds of biological and
biomedical research
in fact omnics logic programs are a
result of close collaboration between
prime biotech an innovative big data
analytics company based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
as a result the onyx logic programs have
been thoroughly tested
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students and faculty
interested in
online training leverages cloud-based
technology to provide high performance
computing access
and detailed training resources making
the learning interactive and practical
the platform offers a streamlined
process from learning to the application
of bioinformatics and life sciences
it is designed for those seeking to make
sense of the big molecular datasets
coming from next generation sequencing
and wanting to leverage computational
advances for processing
analysis and integration of big data
these programs will design to provide
theoretical and practical training
for those interested in the next
generation sequencing data that is now
becoming more and more accessible
on a large variety of topics
in each program you get to learn about
this type of data understand how to
process it prepare it for analysis and
then actually
use to develop a project of your own and
get feedback
from a community of experts and students
we do this because our vision is to make
bioinformatics
accessible not only to bioinformaticians
but for also biologists and clinicians
because we think that this is a critical
skill that
all people involved in life science
research
and are learning about the application
of molecular
precision in medicine need to understand
and use without the necessary
complications
that now exclude many non-experts and
make
conventional tasks extremely burdensome
so today i wanted to introduce you to a
program
specifically designed for africa that we
call bioinformatics
for genomic medicine in this program you
can learn about the role of genomic data
in biomedical
real world examples we will review
literature
literature from chronic and acute
infectious disease studies
seeing how the increasing significance
of novel high throughput data
technologies like next generation
sequencing
are contributing to the application of
omics data analysis to both diagnostic
and treatment selection challenges
we believe that as a result of this
program bioinformatics literacy
is going to increase across all stages
of data generation
processing and utilization in critical
decisions
making it an essential skill for lab
technicians researchers
and clinicians so today i'm going to
talk about
the program different elements of the
program
and answer any questions that you might
have before
joining this program on september 14th
together with our partners we designed
the program for biologists clinicians
and researchers
and we want to make sure that the
students who are interested in advancing
their understanding of big data and life
sciences can join
now this is an introductory program and
it will not require
many of the typical prerequisites for
computational biology training
so you don't need to have any background
in coding bioinformatics or
biostatistics
anyone with a basic familiarity with
cell and molecular biology and an
interest in the future of genomic
medicine will be able to learn
about and apply big data analytics tools
to relevant curated data sets that we've
prepared
and as a result of this short and
focused and effective program
get a certificate of participation that
you can use
to leverage your future studies
so what we'll do in this program is
we'll combine online sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments for an immersive
experience
that has proven to be effective in our
other omixlogic programs that we have
conducted over
time so whenever you
are joining these programs you start by
creating a profile
and we have a free
number of courses that you can try
before you actually join the program
uh you can actually look at how the
material is
organized and centered around your
personal progress
we use a point system to track your
progress and allow you to see
where you are compared to some of the
other people that are
joining these programs we also highlight
those students that have the majority
points and showcase their progress
so for anyone who's interested in
exploring these materials
you can already sign up on edu that t
bio that info
now i want to introduce you today to a
collaborator of ours
um adekunle adulawayo
and uh he's going to speak a little bit
about his personal experience
with a program that he recently
completed
and speak about the significance of
bioinformatics
for genomic medicine but before we do
i wanted to make sure that i can answer
any questions that you might have
about the program that is coming up okay
so
um if you do have a question uh please
put it in the chat box and i will review
all the questions one by one
or raise your hand and we can unmute you
to ask the question by audio
okay abdul rahman
would you like to ask a question
okay
okay so if anyone is having trouble with
technical issues like
audio or um asking the questions
uh please use the chat we can see what
you're writing
and also we will have the recorded
version at the
end that you'll be
able to review
okay so um i'm sorry about the audio it
seems like my audio
is um working
okay okay did anyone have any
questions about this program
wrench me did you want to ask a question
yes so actually i'm a bio engineering
student
from india of second year
and i wanted to do some training courses
shall i be able to do it now or right
now or after some time
no you don't have to have any previous
training in bioinformatics itself it is
very useful to have some basic
terminology about cell and molecular
biology
uh but once you've completed that you
are definitely welcome to join the
program
we work with you individually to make
sure that the material is
understandable and if you're facing any
challenges we'll be
happy to support and answer any
questions you might have
okay thank you so much thank you
okay so if there are any other questions
that you have please put them
in the chat box we'll be answering them
again um and ada
i wanted to invite you to
share your presentation um just a brief
uh background for adekunle he is a
faculty at leeds city university in
nigeria
and he has recently completed an onyx
logic training program
and will share a little bit of his
personal perspective
hello good afternoon
yes we can hear you hello oh great thank
you ellia for having me
um i want to welcome everyone here and
um
i want to appreciate the opportunity to
take us on this journey quickly
okay so um my name
is ade cooley adelu
i'm a faculty from leeds city university
here in nigeria and also double as the
project lead for undergraduate
research and knowledge acquisition and
so this afternoon
i want to talk a little bit about
bioinformatics and the big data science
as well as the new challenges and
opportunities that it presents
so medicine and the feed of diagnostic
practice are both
rapidly changing considerable
technological advances coupled with
a rapid expanding knowledge which allows
clinical
rupees to provide more information than
ever before
is responsible for this
and that as possible in the omics
science era
in this era following the sequencing of
the human genome that was completed in
the year 2001 rapid advances in
knowledge applicable to patient care of
course constantly
as the molecular basis for
constitutional and somatic diseases are
elucidated
along with targets for more effective
treatment
jesus brought in things like
personalized medical practice
so apparently the combination of new
knowledge regarding the molecular
business of
disease welcome to the come zone
however the next important component
that i need
equating much more attention now is key
professionals
that are able to respond adequately to
these opportunities and challenges
and as we know analytic approaches have
advanced significantly in recent years
laboratories uses a variety of methods
to detect mutations and other genomic
abnormalities
and some of these procedures include the
cylindrical synthesis the pyruvate
sequencing allele specific amplification
multiplex methods
such as smpres and
you know a number of other procedures
that characterizes tumors for mutations
as well as you know emerging infectious
diseases
one typical example that comes to mind
would be recognizing pandemic
however the development of the next
generation sequencing platforms
that address the speed cost and troubled
needs of the clinical laboratory
settings has paved the way
for a new era in genomics and its
application across various fees
so the immense amount of complex data
that are generated by necessary
generation sequencing instrumentations
has
you know however meant a challenge to
laboratories and healthcare institutions
requiring concomitant investments and
advances in informatics
and laboratory systems that are able to
handle these data
so the big data challenges are
bioinformatics
of course the interpretation of the
process data is also a challenge
requiring multiple steps and
um informatic tools that are used in
turn them to generate a final result
from the raw data
collectively these software tools are
called the bioinformatics
and the critical part of sample analysis
and generation of results
as we enter into the era of dynamic
science
impact incorporation of genomic
information becomes a routine part of
medical care
all medical professionals especially
biomedical scientists
physicians we need a basic education in
bioinformatics
hi ericander can you hear me
hello
hey uh
eric can you hear me
yeah i hello hear you i don't know if
he's able to hear you or not
yeah i'm not able to see his screen and
i think he should
if he can do the full screen
okay sorry everyone um we're having a
little uh
technical challenge here with uh having
this presentation
from arakumi um maybe because his
internet
connection is not so great um but
we do appreciate um his
uh attempt at showing the screen and
maybe in the meantime
i could switch back and uh talk a little
bit more
um about what we plan to offer
okay so let me share my screen again the
um the significance i think of genomic
medicine
is clear to many of us that are
participating in research and are
learning about
life sciences more and more publications
are abound with next generation
sequencing data that describes
all levels of regulation from genomic to
transcriptomic to epigenomic metagenomic
all of this omic data has specific
processing pipelines and has to be
interpreted
in very specific ways to make sense of
this kind of data so what we wanted to
do in this program
is actually package several of these
basic
topics into a very short and condensed
program that we think many of you will
be able to benefit
from so the program will start on
september 14th
and we will have three sessions hands-on
sessions
interactive and where you will be able
to ask any questions
supported by online asynchronous
curriculum that you can follow
where we will review next generation
sequencing
how can bioinformatics is how is
bioinformatics applied to biomedical
studies
and what is the future of genomic
medicine in the era of coping 19.
so what we'll do is uh briefly explain
what these different topics will cover
in the first one we will talk about the
history of omix data and its
significance
review what the program is going to be
about and introduce you to some of the
resources that we will provide and as a
result of this program
of this session you will be able to
start thinking about
the different types of data in your own
area of research and training
and be able to formulate questions from
a biological perspective
that could be answered with such data
sets now
it's important to understand that many
of these types of
data sets are used to study
a variety of different clinical
conditions
for both diagnostics and therapeutics
development
and accuracy improvement and so we will
review
several examples where all of these
different methods are going to be
important in terms of the logic of how
they connect together and produce the
right kinds of outputs
when we talk about omics data the first
step
is the processing and the integration of
this kind of data
and we see how cellular
condition and variation at the dna rna
and even metagenomic level plays a role
in many diseases when pathogens and
microorganisms in our bodies and the
environment we live in
could be studied to understand the risks
that they pose to acute infection
disease
and chronic risks that actually
destabilize the immune system
and lead to many clinical factors
but when we look at it from a data
perspective
we are faced with another challenge all
of these different data types
come in a variety of formats and so the
first thing that we will do is actually
understand
how different formats could be processed
and
structured so that the data is ready for
analysis and that process is called
processing
so the processing of data is taking the
raw input data sets
and converting them into structured
formats that we could later on
study so then we will have another
session to discuss the precision
medicine and application to virology
we'll talk about several types of
infectious diseases
ebola virus covid19
so all of these pandemics and epidemics
that
happen around us how do we actually
understand these
threats and their emergence as well as
the spread
at the genomic level so how do we
understand the genomic
composition of viral communities how do
we study
the mutations how can we link those
mutations to phenotypes
so we've prepared a few examples case
studies
one of them is ebola virus outbreak in
2014 2016
we know that these outbreaks have
continuously
taken place um over the past
several decades and it's important to
understand
what is the variability at the genomic
level that helps us
both detect prevent and um
prepare interventions for this
important disease and we'll do this
based on
a particular uh set of publications that
actually
characterizes the history of how
through the sequencing efforts of many
different organizations
the viral spread was tracked
the different strains were detected and
characterized the biology of the virus
was understood at a much greater
level and as a result new interventions
were designed
based on particular understanding of how
the disease
works and what kinds of disease
progression
changes happen at both the virus and the
host level
we'll also talk about covenanting and
discuss
how sequencing has changed our
understanding
of these novel coronavirus outbreaks
and what we can learn from the current
outbreak in
around the world but also the emergence
of those outbreaks
related to different types of hosts and
interaction between
humans and other animals around us
we'll also talk about infectious
diseases that are
causing chronic conditions that turn to
cancer
and a continuous inflammation that
actually
results in hundreds of thousands of
cases of cancer every year
and some of these infectious agents are
actually
detected in fairly early stages
so our ability to detect and treat
that process is critical for a healthier
future
everywhere around us finally on
september 18th
we'll talk about genomic medicine in and
post
covert 19. so as a result of these
outbreaks and particularly infectious
disease outbreaks
we've seen the adoption and the
reliability
as well as the value of genomics
in many different scenarios as we
think for the future and as this type of
data
becomes more accessible and easier to
incorporate
into a clinical workflow we have to be
able to
both analyze and interpret the findings
from these types of sequencing studies
so
we hope that as a result of these three
sessions
you will know many different types of
data
and have a sense of a few examples of
how you can apply this data to study
infectious diseases and chronic diseases
as well as
ask specific basic research questions
of the publicly available data sets that
are becoming more and more rich with
data so we're going to take a look
at not only the interactive sessions but
we'll also
provide you access with some coursework
and projects that you can review
these are asynchronous courses so you
can actually
join those courses without participating
in the program
or by participating in the program they
will be organized
in such a fashion that you will be
benefiting from completing the
coursework before
joining the interactive sessions as i
mentioned before
this is available for different levels
of students
faculty and clinicians so we have a
wide range of backgrounds that we see
from our participants
and they all benefit from completing the
basic coursework
as well as then working on project
examples
and here you can see the ebola virus and
the novel coronavirus projects
as you kind of get access to these
different data sets
you can then actually develop your own
independent project
that you can work on for your research
objectives so i think that
this is an important part of not only
application of basic research but as i
mentioned the clinical biomedical
studies that have
a tremendous significance for the future
of medicine
as well as biodefense and
surveillance of emerging infectious
diseases
now at the end of the program you are
offered a
certificate of completion or a
certificate of
excellence and in this program we are
hoping to provide you with a real
hands-on view of what a program like
this a training program like this can
mean for you
we've seen students with minimal
bioinformatics background
come out of these programs ready to
apply their skills to a project and we
have a supporting community
that is working on different types of
data sets
different types of projects where
you might be able to benefit from
interacting with them
so just a couple of examples and then
i'll
leave some more time for uh questions as
well
um uh emika patrick chukwuka
is a laboratory specialist at the
maternity and children's hospital in
al-mubaraz he has been with us
uh for a number of different programs
and we've seen
how he was able to first of all apply
the
tools and skills that he's acquired to
one particular uh type of a project and
then expand his interest and now
applying these skills to many different
areas
as well as topi okitaki
who is a principal research officer at
the biotechnology department in
niomr in lagos nigeria
who was able to benefit from both the
courses that he has completed
and the tools that we provide during the
program so an important part of what we
do
is not only provide you with theoretical
content or tell you
how to do this on your computer many of
these data sets
are huge you actually have to rely on a
comprehensive cloud infrastructure that
allows you to process large data sets
and potentially do this many times to
actually get to a meaningful outcome
now some of the participants of our
previous programs
have not only learned this in an
academic perspective uh olga udartseva
for example
is a research affiliate a postdoc at
roswell park comprehensive cancer center
um she was able to complete a program
but also enhance the projects that she
is working on
in her research pre-clinical research
studies
and think about the practical
applications to cancer patients that she
interacts with
so i think that again this is not only
for doing basic research and maybe
improving your skills but actually
applying this
in the context of genomic medicine as
well um
so at this point i wanted again to open
this for
questions and see that there's a couple
of people
okay so um for the
course price i will actually walk you
through
how to join register set up your account
and see what courses are included in the
program
the program itself is not free but we
are hoping that we made it
as affordable as possible even in africa
so the cost is actually
uh ten dollars so let me go back to that
slide
um with the pricing so you can see that
this is a one week online program
uh that provides you with access to some
of the synchronous courses that i've
mentioned
you can access those courses
independently or a part of this program
you will also get one-on-one q a and
assistance throughout this program
our objective is to really reach out to
academic institutions
that can make this available to their
students
so we're actively looking for partners
in nigeria and africa in general that
would be able to
introduce this at their university and
develop joint academic programs to offer
it to students
the cost for this particular
introductory program
i think is very affordable at 10 and
if you register this week you will
actually be able to get it for only
eight dollars
there's a an early bird discount there
as well
um if you if anyone else has any
questions you're welcome to post those
in the chat box what i wanted to do is
show you actually how to register
and um set up your account
um so if everyone can follow me to
this website edu dot t dash bio dot info
i will show you how you can access the
free
coursework as well as how you can
register for the program and thank you
beepster for
posting that link so please let me know
once you are here
um on this website edu bio.info
okay if you've reached this site please
type in yes i will
just keep it on for a couple of minutes
to make sure that everybody can
join me there
okay and the second link is a link for
pre-registration
okay great thank you all right
all right so i'll just wait until a
couple of you
are here
now if you go under events
in the main menu you will see here
bioinformatics
genomics africa so please navigate to
this
link and again if all right great so
more people are getting there that's
excellent
so what you will see once you navigate
to bioinformatics for genomics
in africa you will see the home page for
this program
and here you have
this button to register for membership
so actually
from this button you'll be able to
complete your registration
so there is a link for pre-registration
but that pre-registration
actually only gives us um
the information about you to reach out
to you
okay and uh for a welly
decided to go through the courses and
sometimes they copy out the link to see
if i can access it on my modules
app to make it easier for me but then
the courses that are written in the
language they can't understand
um again you do need to have some basic
background and cell molecular biology if
it's a terminology
issue if there are particular challenges
in access of a particular course please
do let us know well
okay so here you can either sign up
using a username and email and add your
name to your profile
or since i already have an account i can
log in so you do have to have an account
before you can complete your
registration so here i'm just going to
log in with my email
again for those of you that are facing
any kind of
technical challenges with accessing this
we are aware of some problems that might
happen
because of slow internet
or things like that and so we have
thought about that as well
so please do let us know our goal is to
make this as
accessible as possible so any feedback
is actually helpful
okay again i will um you click here
register for
membership and here you will see what is
included in your membership registration
so you can have a discount code
you get this discount code if you fill
out the pre-registration
form and the pre-registration form is
down here at the bottom so you just
fill out your information right here and
you will receive an email
from marketing at time.bio
and that email will contain a discount
code
and that code is going to be available
up until
the end of this week okay and here you
can complete your payment
we understand that uh some payments is
going to be restricted for international
payments and so we also have an
alternative way
and uh um adekunle is helping many of
the participants
that are interested in registering uh
using some payment in africa bank in
africa
so please do let us know if you are
having challenges
completing the payment there is a pay
stack option
okay so what is in the program let's go
back to the program
and i'll kind of give you an overview so
we already have
a number of people that have completed
their registration we only have
several more spots left
that we hope will be interesting to
those of you that want to join over the
course of the next two weeks
the programs are organized by combining
coursework
and projects that you can have access to
and explore
some of these topics in greater detail
you also have
a series of sessions that are described
under your um okay
so here are the courses that we will go
through introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to genomics an introduction
to metagenomics
you also can see the full syllabus of
the program
right here and on the syllabus you'll
see the specific dates where we will be
meeting
and this is going to always happen
between 6 30 pm
and 8 pm western african time
you can see that for each session
there's an adjacent course that you can
complete
and as you join you will also have
access to a
forum so we use this forum to interact
and discuss
any technical issues or questions that
you might have
now there are some free courses here as
well
you're welcome to explore those as well
you can just navigate
to the courses tab and you will see a
number of free courses that you
can take before you join the program
so this is a brief overview of the
program schedule
again this is the link that you can
explore
in your own free time share it with your
academic institution and students that
you
might have this course will provide you
with access
to our interactive big data analysis
platform so i'll just briefly show you
what that
looks like as well as insight into
some parts of these different types of
analysis that we'll use
in the program to explain how the
analysis works
so one of the things that we will do is
look
at the somatic mutations
in the content of mutation variant
column
so here you will see that all of the
practical assignments are going to be
available
even for those that have minimal
background in coding and big data
analysis
for each step of the way you will be
able to
learn about the specific analysis that
is being performed
uh you'll also see the logic of analysis
uh why different types of methods are
used for what kind of objective
as you build your pipeline
you'll learn about each one of the
methods and can read more about the
relevant publications that
are included and then
also understand the inputs and
outputs of each one of your pipelines
so here's an example you will get a
file that you can download and then open
on your computer
and understand what are some of these
somatic mutations
that we were able to do we will also
review
sections related to phylogenetic
analysis
as well as evolution
and viral quasi species
so here you can see
some examples as well this by the way
is a link that you can also take a look
at this is our research platform that we
will be
using but it leverages a lot of the open
source
type material so here you can see an
example from a study
related to the origins of source code
2.
this introductory program will be just
one week long
it's a very brief program for us to get
started with
and we will announce some future courses
after this program is completed so here
you can see how we can leverage
the translation from nucleotide
sequences to amino acid sequences
and study codon and amino acid variation
using multiple types of phylogenetic
analysis and also understand
how we can study the outputs of
different types of phylogenetic analysis
methods
using tree space
and then we will look at different types
of outputs
that include some basic as well as
interactive
overview of what is in our data
so here's an interactive output from the
pipeline
um here for example you can see uh
the different types of coronaviruses
compared to each other
mers stars covered 19
and beta corona viruses it's important
to understand not only the sequence
variation but also the
impact that the sequence variation has
on specific
uh unspecific proteins so we will do a
detailed study on how we can analyze
such raw data
how to find this raw data how to analyze
it
how to look at the results and then how
to interpret the results
from a biological or a biomedical
perspective
so as you go through some of these
coursework
uh some of these courses that are
included here these are the types of
examples that we will review with a
detailed explanation of the methods as
well as some practical assignments that
you can
practice on your own
what are the things that you already
have access to before the training
commences
so yes there is an email that will go
out to you
after you have completed your
registration you do
have access to these courses already
that you can start learning from
what will happen during the actual
sessions for the program is we will have
an
interactive overview and in that
interactive overview
we will go into greater detail for some
of the methods that we've discussed
okay another resource that we will cover
and that you will have access to um
after registering
is our coding platform so on this coding
platform you will be able
to understand some of the methods that
we have discussed
but at a code level so you're probably
familiar with
r and python both of these
are widely used in biomedical research
biostatistical analysis
and machine learning and so we will have
a few examples where you will be able to
do
such activities like sequence analysis
and visualization
of analyzed data using r and python
so i'll just give you a brief example of
what these courses
look like you'll have a tutorial on how
to set up
your environment and load the data
and then we'll actually have again
access to cloud-based tools
where you actually perform a simple
modification uh to the code
that you can check on how
it works so for example here you can see
that i loaded
a data set got some output
and now i can actually uh change
the next one again run it this is actual
uh actual
you can see output from r so if i use
the same example link here it's not
going to work because this is supposed
to be
in excel so you can see how
just copying and pasting is not going to
work you actually have to
practice and understand the code so you
can see success running code
and so forth and so this is also a
resource that is included
in this program subscription again the
program itself will last for
uh one week but it's a great way to
start learning about these different
skills
even if you are just a beginner or
if you are already doing research in
microbiology
oncology biomedical informatics
bioinformatics computational biology
we've had many different participants
from around the world
that have joined these programs now
after this program is
over we're going to have more
comprehensive programs that you're also
welcome to join as well
these programs as you are usually
organized by different types of data
or different type of specializations so
if you explore the site
in general you'll see other types of
programs that are coming up
like a program on metagenomics or
bioinformatics for infectious
diseases or transcriptomics these are
much more
in-depth programs they are typically
around two weeks to a month
they are designed to work on independent
research projects
so you can see here in this particular
example
this program is going to be starting on
september 14th as well
this program is going to have a lot more
information it's going to be much longer
um but we we're um you know happy to
invite you to those programs as well so
i'm just going to give you
a couple of links where you can explore
some of these other programs as well so
this is an
omixlogic transcriptomics program for
those of you that
are more familiar with these types of
next-generation sequencing technologies
and again we also would recommend
thinking about this not just as a
theoretical
certificate program but as a program
that allows you to
develop an independent project
so
you can see some of our participants
from previous programs
have developed project research projects
of their own
and you can see here um
what is the process that we go through
for those that are interested to apply
the skills that they have learned to
develop an independent project
and here's some project examples uh that
you can see
from our previous participants
okay so at this moment again i'll open
it back up for
any questions or comments that you might
have
about the program itself um or some of
the tools that we've
described here um you're welcome to
submit your pre-registration for this
particular program to get a
discount code and benefit from a
discount
for this week or just
register directly and if you need any
assistance
with completing your payment you can
reach out to ada coonley
by email and also be in touch with our
support team
that is working to make this program
available
i think if you don't mind sharing your
email also if people have any questions
they could reach out to you and hear
back
about what their questions might be
uh elia i wanted to add something uh can
you please go back
to the organization page once uh there
was a question that we had in
um the telegram group and i just wanted
to point something out
uh for everyone who had been uh telling
me that you know they are
seeing uh if you go to the home a once
earlier
thank you uh that you are seeing that
you know there is a registration for
membership even even after you have
signed up so that button is something
uh which will be there and if you have
access to the forum the courses and all
the other
aspects of this organization page that
means that it is good but
even then if you are having any problem
with the access
let me know because i know that paul and
a few others were having some problems
and also there is one more thing that i
would want to point out
it's signing up to the edu site with one
email id so your one email id
is your identity it could be any one so
if you want to change something you can
let me know so that we can do it right
before the program starts
and once you uh use that email id it
would be used for all of the platforms
that you will have access to
like the youtube platform uh from which
you can access
the genomic medicine uh course and then
the server platform so please make sure
that you're using
the email id uh which you're paying for
that is the correct one and if you want
to change
it just let me know so thank you that's
all
okay excellent thank you
and also thank you everyone for joining
today
we will have the recording of this
webinar for you available
again we're sorry for some of the
technical issues that we've had
and we're happy to stay in touch so
please let us know if you have any
other questions